Stephanie is on the line in New York I
Stephanie how are you I'm good day how
are you today better than I deserve how
can I help you yes so my husband and I
are in baby step two and he owns his own
small business doing engineering surveys
and we're kind of freaking out at the
moment because that business is quickly
drying up and you know he still has that
within his business I'm still working
which is good I have a really good job
in corporate finance which hopefully
will survive this crisis but we're just
trying to figure out what we do do we
continue moving on with baby step two do
we cause and just you know put money in
savings until we know what what happens
next
what do you make I think about a hundred
and twenty thousand years y'all live on
that I think so
you know my you know me issues we have
two kids in daycare and you know pretty
high bill and we've got some debt still
outstanding I think we can make it know
what kind of debt have you got
outstanding I've got student loans of
about thirty thousand what among
hardship to find any okay we've got an
HVAC loan which is small it's only a
hundred dollars and then we have a
consumer line of credit which it's
interest only but that's the next done
or snowball that we were trying to pay
down you know it's got about 10 grand
left on it yeah okay what I would do is
pretend he's gonna have no income for 30
to 60 days okay and batten up the
hatches and we live on your income and
that means you don't you're not doing
any baby steps you're pushing pause and
piling up yeah even if you pile up some
cash even if you pay all your payments
and have some money left over which is
my preference by the way let's build
your emergency fund as high as you can
build it in the next 60 days and then as
things get back to normal and his income
adds back to the household sixty days
from now push play again on your on your
baby steps and kick back into gear okay
and knowers take any money you got saved
at that point throw it at your debts I'm
sorry okay I can ask you one more
question
if you wait laughter this break I'll put
you on ho all right we were talking with
Stephanie in New York and she said she
had another question so let's go the
second question is Stephanie hi Dave as
a small business owner do you think we
should have an emergency fund that's
higher than $1,000 just for
uncertainties like this I just want some
sort what your take was on small
business owners and if they need to have
an emergency fund this little a little
larger to go yeah we teach not not at
home but at the business and we teach
small business owners to at the business
to pay yourself if you have debt
associated with the business and you
don't have any retained earnings which
is a business phrase for the written you
know that you're in finance right that
is that is for that's for opportunities
as well as emergencies but you want to
have routine you want to have a goal of
having retained earnings of three to six
months in cash there that's a heavy
liquidity position for business and
honestly our business has grown so fast
over the years we've never been able to
get there we've got millions of dollars
of retained earnings but I've never been
able to get to 3 to 6 months because
every time I get close the business adds
expenses we have payroll you know we
have a thousand people so it just keeps
getting bigger that the what it takes to
cover that nut and so that's the thing
and but yeah but but what I tell
business owners is not the standard baby
steps at home is to do will pay yourself
a living wage the least you can take
reasonably out of the business no
luxuries and beyond that take all of
your other profits and put a percentage
towards that and a percentage towards
retained earnings instead of bonusing
yourself out excess profits until you
build the retained earnings up or until
you're out of debt I actually say let's
put 7080 percent of that money
percentage towards the debt and the
other 20-30 percent towards continually
building you retained earnings so that
you've got a little bit of cushion
because you become your own credit line
or you go further in a debt when stuff
happens right right that's exactly
what's happening yeah so let's just
let's just try to hold the line on it
and not you know if we just keep his
business breaking even and you guys
eating off your salary you're gonna be
okay